i hope you lot are happy with yourselves
been looking forward to this video this
is thomas so which of you knows thomas
you so what's your name um i'm jessica
jessica and why is thomas upset with us
um thomas is upset because i've um
postponed a date for the second time so
i could come and and be here and meet
guys
i'm getting a slime for everything
is it is it your boyfriend no no i we
have not been on a date yet because like
so you put him up why did you put him
off for the first time
my sister and this time kylie okay you
know that book not that into you
but are you in are you into him
you don't know
really not that into him she's she's
fogged him off twice yeah can i suggest
you take him out tomorrow night when
this is on
this is a story all about how my life
got flipped don't you dare
hello who's there hello sir hello what's
your name thomas okay and where are you
from i'm from durham durham all right
but you live here now yes okay very good
off you go with this story thomas uh so
i asked a girl a couple of weeks ago and
she said yes uh which was great because
she's quite hot and they're like i
really got a job
[Applause]
once and then we rescheduled for
cancelled on me tonight
so she could come here and watch kylie
minogue
so
i had no plans tonight i thought i'd
come down and see if she wanted to
rearrange for next week
wow
whatever you say thomas you're very keen
because she has given you no indication
that she is
oh dear well i guess he didn't look the
good thing is he didn't make other plans
that's good yeah okay so so this is your
decision now this is you this is you
sending a message to him
so jessica are we going to flip thomas
or are we going to let thomas walk this
is oh okay
please
kylie please will you lever him off the
red
[Applause]
one chairs one more here we go here we
go hello hi um hi what's your name my
name is sebastian sebastian and where
are you from i'm from newcastle
newcastle okay do you live there or here
uh i live in newcastle yeah okay uh off
you go with the george sebastian well uh
many moons ago um
i actually went to school in newcastle
um and
there was a disco coming up
uh there was a really popular girl at
school
um the usual side of scenario all the
you know all the guys after her um
i sort of waited to the last moment last
couple of days um and asked the girl
what this popular girl question if she'd
like to go with me
she said yes this was literally i think
the day before the disco
um
lo and behold the it turns out that she
was actually gonna go with somebody else
um and that other person was actually
charlie
sebastian olympia
that's the real man
[Applause]
how could this have happened to two
people
[Applause]
rachel gould
the very same yes you know who it is
and did you end up marrying rachel gould
um no not yet no okay
there's still time you don't happen to
have a sword with you do you
uh
you you could you could add revenge if
you want to do you want to
there you go
all those years
okay so
i'm here tonight to surprise my
beautiful wife alma yeah alma yeah see
she actually in the audience tonight oh
where's alma
are you sure she may have left
them
yes she's gone
no your beautiful wife alma's still here
off you go valeria is this a nice
surprise oh yes of course okay she's
pregnant or our first baby
oh
we don't know yet the gender of the baby
oh yes because i really want weight
until the baby's born of course but she
really want to know as soon as possible
oh yes so the doctor
wrote
on this piece of paper oh the gender of
the baby
and i say to her we will open in a
special occasion oh yes
so because she really loves you and your
show yes i believe that tonight is the
best
may i open yes
[Applause]
here we go so alma
emma are you ready it'll be a boy or a
girl
and even the boy you're calling it wayne
here we go here we go the babies it's a
girl
hello hi yeah uh what's your name my
name is elaine
aylin yep i i'm guessing you're from
ireland i am i'm from jerry oh you're
from derrick from the north of the
country okay and you live there or here
uh story here i live over there oh what
what what are you saying
uh costume design hush interpretation
okay there will be subtitles on friday
right now only i can understand
so far you're not missing anything
i've never heard of costume
interpretation
it's like costume design isn't it it's
not fancier fancy it's fancier frank
oh yeah oh yeah yeah all the labor
okay off you go right so lead up to
christmas i was back home um
and having a good exact face
you get any of it crystal something
about christmas yeah christmas that's
the only good detail so far
just pick out words you'll follow the
story say blah blah blah christmas blah
blah blah
i've gone into the shop and i had to get
milk and bread
so i literally was really stressed so i
was like run and roll out get the
groceries let's go told my boyfriend to
do a lap and just pick me up no need to
park the car so as planned i came out
you know perfect timing uh silver people
carrier just
casually drifts by casual speed so
without hesitation i sprung across when
we look we made groceries
jump in the back of the car screaming
and thumping the back of the chair show
them go go go go go
but taking in mind it was christmas and
i had like a scarf up here
which was my boyfriend turned out to be
this middle-aged like six-year-old woman
oh
no i live in london but i'm originally
from um suffolk
oh
oh yeah it's a suffolk massive yeah
is he mentioned in the song probably
yeah
what school did you go to um so i went
to brandeston that was sweet yeah i i
went to primary school yeah oh okay
did we know each other
[Applause]
glasses what do you yeah james hello
yeah james yes me that's the one what
the [__]
dude he was my best mate growing up
and now you're talking to me on a
monastery
i'm not wearing my specs and he's like
oh my god oh can we not flip him and
just get him out here yeah
do you have a story or do you well yeah
i did but please let it be about edge
here's about it okay okay tell your
story that will flip you and then i'll
sit with you
okay
okay cool so um yeah
this is so random mate
it's really weird um yeah when we were
younger ed used to come around to my
house and yeah like you're saying we
used to be quite good mates and i
remember one time um
one time he was gone around for tea and
i'd forgotten to tell mum that he was a
vegetarian
at that point anyway and um so mum
cooked i think the sausage and mash for
tea
and ed said you know after the meal
these are the best sausages i've ever
tasted you know where did you get them
from a mum had to lie because she had no
clue um and so yeah
16 years later i'm really sorry first
time i ever had me and also the first
time i ever watched the simpsons episode
was around your house as well
i feel like silla black on surprise
surprise
there he is
come on will you just
will you just say randomly oh
have a seat have a seat dude
[Applause]
[Music]
you